You know,
I got a new bit about,
uh,
seeing a couple of fucking in
the hotel room across from me.
Yeah.
So I won't do the bit,
but I'll tell you the story,
which is basically nears,
even Portland.
The hotel is like a horseshoe shape.
So I'm on the 10th floor and I look
across into a room and the curtains are
open,
lights are on,
chick is on her back,
legs up.
And this dude who's ripped his fucking
hour dinner and I'm just standing there
looking at him like,
like this is the greatest thing I've
ever greatest things ever happened.
I got,
I slept my bag in my hand
and I'm just transfixed.
And He,
uh,
keeps fucking,
I'm like high five and the
glass like go man had then.
And so I had the curtain closed
cause I didn't want them to see me,
but I popped my head through the curtain.
I looked like a photographer
from the 1930 [inaudible]
and then I start thinking
about what am I sound like?
And this is where it gets creepy,
creepy year is I leave my room,
I walked down the hall and I stand outside
the room and I listen and I hear him
grunting and I hear her go,
oh,
to my room,
and I call the room.
No,
just watching them,
waiting,
and he didn't pick up.
But if he did,
I would have been like,
yeah.